hey YouTube averse and the other grass
Tyson here for a star talk coming up an
exploration of our relationship with
robots be there this is Startalk I'm
Neil deGrasse Tyson your personal
astrophysicist and today I got with this
and there's like someone between us I
know this is we're always fist bumping
in somebody's face it's somebody's face
yeah today we're talking about robots in
fact that's not only what we're gonna do
that's the title of the show talking
about talking about robot talking about
robots and those we have as our studio
guest Kate darling Kate welcome double
fist bump give it here with us you were
a robot ethicist didn't even know that
was a thing we'll get into that in a
minute from the MIT Media Lab of course
in Cambridge Massachusetts where else
would an MIT lab be and what we're
featuring today is my interview with
Anthony Daniels Anthony you don't
manuals oh she's getting all nerdy these
nerd out on that one ah the actor who
portrayed oh you want the gig I love me
oh you want the gig um in particular
we're not just talking about robots
we're talking about relationships
Oh robots okay between humans and robots
and we don't even know what that means
entirely not at the moment
now the movie AI kind of covered it yeah
okay yeah all right all right
but of course c-3po is from the Star
Wars franchise one of most successful
movie franchises in his ever was and
just let me get a little bit of
background on you Kate so did you come
to this from robotics no no well I've
always loved robots but I'm a social
scientist nice I have a legal background
I did social sciences and now I study
human robot interaction from a social
legal and
perspectives Wow Wow so this so so it is
it's good to learn that someone such as
you exists in that world yes we should
have somebody like you in all of the the
potentially troubled places where where
technology is going everywhere yeah
everywhere so you have a book that may
be coming out in 2021
yeah our title ears it's the right one
the new breed what our history with
animals reveals about our future with
machines that is it that is a awesome
title it really is
so is this MIT press gonna publish this
no it's actually Henry Holt Henry Holt
I'm just gonna get out there let me go
get to my first clip with Anthony
Daniels and we'll sort of react to that
so he's the only actor that was an all 9
Star Wars movies Wow all 90 official not
right not the the fan offer amp
right exactly he's the only actor
there's been all in all nine and he's
also the author of I am c-3po the inside
story cool you see what he did there
there and what I particularly loved
about him was a visiting professor
Carnegie Mellon's entertainment
Technology Center so he's got some
academic chops that little Credle sweet
little academic street cred so I'm gonna
loving me that so what is it about c-3po
is it his performance his the way he
speaks that that people could relate to
him so deeply oh gosh c-3po was amazing
I think I think what it is actually is
that c-3po looks like a robot but acts
kind of like a human like he's very
flawed and has all these human emotions
and I think people just relate to him
ironically because he's so human like oh
so oh so it's the opposite it's not like
he's the perfect robot and we're finding
a way to relate to that right it's that
he's he has enough human in him so that
he's an imperfect robot right and that's
what we're related is that what you just
told me yeah yeah well you know that
makes sense because
that is what makes us human they're like
you know the fact that we are flawed and
imperfect and kind of annoying and
definitely not kind of definitely
annoying you know so I kind of liked it
when he when he got a little excited
that was just kind of fun it was like
hey that's kind of cool yeah exactly so
that's so it's the human side of the
robot that we're relating to sometimes
yeah in that case in that case for sure
okay and so so then what would be harder
than do you think playing or a robot as
an actor or acting as a human well I
guess it depends like what robot like
are we talking right that'd be kind of
cool though you could play a room but
well you know that I think that would
take some real acting jobs a little
differently so what is it about him
other than its costume that told you
he's a robot in how he's interacting
with people what is the evidence that
he's a robot other than he's a shiny
metal right he's right I mean a lot of
it is the design I'm trying to remember
anything like specifically robotic that
he said see I don't think so
other than I know 80 trillion Mike right
is that yes right no we don't know human
would so that's a robot talent right but
I think of what is the visual in the way
he moves yes and he does it looks like
he's actually doing the dance the robot
yeah of course you know what you want to
do if you want to be a contemporary
robot though is fall over a lot oh yeah
oh you mean like actual robots I thought
you guys were just talking about movie
robots cuz that's what like right now
movie robots what's your actual robot
why would I bring here to talk what do
you think I'm talking to you know I know
we're talking about that on the show I
just thought that's what you were
referencing right now because well let's
go to a clip so I sat down with Anthony
Daniels and I did you know he wasn't
always a fan of sci-fi I really remember
he got that first check
[Laughter]
let's find out what was he up to before
he landed where he did check it out
maybe I've been traumatized did you
never thought of this I had been bashed
around the head by 2001 a Space Odyssey
to the point where I never wanted to see
another spaceship oh that was a long
movie with very little dialogue there's
no character development except for the
how the computer well you like that so
it's a very different intersect of genre
yeah it's not even science fiction it's
some other it's a science portrait in a
way it was almost a reporter Asafa chol
treat eyes on a man and a man versus
space man-machine in space and so there
we are so I didn't want to go because
back then the only robot that I
remembered really with the Daleks on
television all the Daleks yes so so
every night you know doctor who would
sink plungers on the merica faces I mean
cute and as a kid I adored them but as
an acting role not so much then there
was Robby before them Robby the Robot in
was it hidden planet Forbidden Planet
and he was this kind of lumbering thing
made a mission entires really it seemed
to me because they had these horizontal
segments that's right and he lumbered in
kind of unprepossessing my iPhone but
anyway are you judging the acting
talents of a robot convincingly
Lama and when you read on page 95 that I
met mr. Kinoshita who designed him and I
said joyfully Oh what was it like to see
your design come off the Pape and you
went not so good I didn't mean him to
kind of Lombok and I said so also you
get why Threepio kind of teachers around
because it's more character for more
forgiving more human anyways yeah
because because the Robby the Robot was
I'm saying robotic not he just didn't
there was no they had the
that was it whereas c-3po there were
sort of body gestures that could help
communicate
that's what mood and it's all I had
really right because there's no this is
not a moving mouth here you'd be
surprised how many people think it's
makeup that I'm I'm wearing no it's a
solid we all saw Goldfinger so just a
couple years huh yeah she was prettier
than the woman the woman who was painted
gold and gold in Goldfinger so he was
referencing his book I am c-3po and he
said on page 95 right so Kate how has we
talked about a few generations of robots
there how has our concept of robot
evolved from the beginning until now
that's a good question I mean I feel
like it used to be that anything that
was even remotely automata and could
move on its own was viewed as a robot
and now we have a little bit more that
we expect a robot to be able to do in
behavior right because in fact now so
when do when does it become an android
robot an Android is a robot that looks
deceptively human-like Lieutenant
Commander data
yes yes data my favorite Android and
then there's c-3po which is more of a
humanoid robot so like oh yeah yeah so
androids look realistic humanoids just
have a kind of human shape torso head
arms legs but not r2d2 not r2d2 so which
r2d2 he's just a robot damn with no ID
on it
right oh you're just a robot okay so but
presumably all three kinds of robots are
still legit in storytelling today oh
yeah for sure
okay but we don't have the big Robby the
Robot kinds anymore those the lumbering
right with with its circuits turning in
the warning Will Robinson warning right
that was a Robbie robot style exactly
yes in lost in space lost in space
warning Will Robinson danger that not
warning danger real whoppers with the
arms would be flailing right and then
practice with you know
it's before her time are you kidding me
you don't have TV land I feel like I
just saw it though you really did in a
way you know but I did you acted all the
character I did it no justice but very
very quickly here it is where'd you grow
up we only sing you the crime the TV
show anyway there get out more they're
traveling they're traveling em
intergalactically right and or maybe
just within our galaxy who knows but
they get lost and it's a family no way
to get lost to get lost in space and and
then there's a doctor who were not sure
if he's a doctor or not and they let him
go off with their son all the time and a
robot and that's where that comes from
so at what point do you inform a person
who might be trying to design a robot in
terms of its personality or its
character or how they would best be an
actor doing so Duke are you in that
equation at some point well you are
consultant I mean I do I work with
roboticists a lot in social robotics and
the it you know we have more and more
robots coming into shared spaces and
they have to you know interact with
people and not all robots it's a shared
space oh you know a workplace household
public ok stop and job as robots roam in
the aisles now yeah you could call they
are indeed a robot but it's more like an
obelisk on wheels with googly eyes penis
[Laughter]
so it goes up and down the aisles yeah
and there's no one controlling it no
one's controlling there's no choice it
actually moves about like a Roomba like
you know except it doesn't have to touch
things assume it doesn't bump into the
orange it does it does the orange stack
right but I think I've never engaged
with them personally but I think you can
ask them questions and they will direct
you to places in the store right I got
it the next time I see one I'm doing all
experiments on it Oh Mike I I might have
gone to Savage shop last weekend with
Daniella who's one of the students in
the personal robotics lab who is
obsessed with this robot and we might
have like put stuff in front of the
robot to see what it did you might just
mine what happened well they might have
done it they didn't what might have
happened
what were you testing it for you didn't
get kicked out yet we're gonna go back
what were you testing it for but we just
wanted to see what it would do because
the purpose of the robot is to find
hazards on the floor and alert someone
to come pick them up and so we wanted to
know what's the other route for clean up
all four yep and so right now what I
wonder what it would do if you just laid
down in the floor like on the floor in
front of it like what it would do if
it's actually if go around you see
that's a robot No so you'll recognize a
spill but I just had a damn heart attack
and just go around you go around me
really so somebody drops a jar pickles
it's a huge monumental problem we you
know somebody to get here right away and
you can't get up another robot you're
just in the way exactly
instead of hitting my med alert bracelet
you're just like okay so that's the
thing though like when designing robots
you have to think about how like what's
gonna be frustrating to people when
they're interacting with it and they're
gonna be like why isn't helping me do X
when they don't understand that building
a robot is really really hard and like
they only have very limited capabilities
and so roboticists really need to think
not just about how they're working but
how people are gonna perceive them they
only have limited capabilities now right
yeah yes as an actor mm-hmm okay
he he's best known for c-3po but he
almost didn't take the gig oh yeah let's
find out why okay check it out so that
there we were playing thinking about
playing a robot and the thing that
really changed my mind was reading the
words that I had
written George and his team had written
them pretty much George
and clearly he he had invented a machine
with more human characteristics than he
could apply to a human being you
couldn't get away with Han Solo being
the character of Threepio if we'll see
what I mean
so Threepio was allowed to have intense
humanity because he isn't a machine he
isn't it he is a human that's that's
that's deep no yes it is because what
you're saying is with a machine who is
sort of human but he's still a machine
yeah you can take it to human places
that would be unconvincing if written
for a human carrot and slightly
uncomfortable there are there is a film
called Bicentennial man with I never got
to see there ha it's interesting Robin
Williams beautiful guy I had loved to
meet him a couple of times no we didn't
talk about it but that was a slightly
uncomfortable film because the the
storyteller was was he was transitioning
from a robot that arrived in a packing
case you know from Amazon or somewhere
whatever the Amazon equivalent was back
when that movie was made and then
gradually he metamorphoses into into a
human and it's slightly uncomfortable
because it veers towards pushing our
humanity buttons thank what what does it
take to be human and where are we
slightly uncomfortable through the
uncanny valley and beyond well tell us
about the uncanny valley because that's
that's it's it's a great name but it
still has to be defined for people to
know what it is it is often used in in
games or in visuals or in film to sit or
in computer terms the the Turing test
almost gets there but it's when
something is almost real it looks great
and it speaks nicely and has great skin
for instance in a robot but there's
something that's not quite right
there's something that we sniff as a
human being that not quite there so it's
it's even unconscious within us
perhaps it's innate within us innate
that's a better word right right you're
not you
you don't even know how to verbalize it
yeah and so people have coined this
phrase the uncanny valley because you
know there's something not quite right
Kate
do all humans respond to the uncanny
valley the same way so people have
tested this theory empirically with very
mixed results but most people who work
in robotics seem to think that there's
something there and they're wrong
let me save me a lot of money you're
wrong save all the academics or other
academics who are researching this
forever you're right what you're talking
about is the perception of normal
humanity that's why you can't put your
finger on it because it doesn't exist we
feel the same way about human beings
that may have some type of brain
disorder and we talk to them and we go
oh something not quite right here but
you don't say they're not a human being
but that's really what your that's what
your perceptions are telling you so what
you're talking about is the normal
perception of humanity as opposed to
what makes someone human and they're two
different things I think you're right I
think I brought a comedy thing doesn't
work out why are you in the lab all
right
well for me the uncanny valley has
always been about expectation management
because you're expecting something to
behave a certain way if it looks human
you're expecting it to blink like a
human and not twitch its face and if it
doesn't that kind of unsettles you if it
does something that you're not expected
nobody the little things that we don't
we're not even conscious of that affirm
for us or are some affirm to our
subconscious you're communicating with a
genuine human being yeah right but see
you know what's funny is that I fell for
it once over the phone and it was a
robot and I talked to it for about I
don't know 15 seconds which is a long
time
any that you have issues I do clearly I
can't figure out who's human or not but
it was just I don't know what it was
that tipped me but it was like the the
cadence you know what I mean the cadence
of the I started to speak and that
stopped
but it's the way it stopped and then I
went is this person real and then it
clicked off like it hung up Wow
bus did well so what do you what do
programmers yourself what do you all do
in the Media Lab to either exploit that
uncanny valley or to dodge it I don't
think anyone wants to exploit it but I
also don't understand why we would try
to create something that looks like a
human or talks like a human because we
can create anything we want
why create like well I try to like risk
this uncanny valley creepiness factor
when we can create an r2d2 that
communicates and beeps do you tell this
to your peeps back at MIT oh yeah I like
everyone I think in the social robotics
field agrees that making you know
human-like robots is not as interesting
as making something that had it has
better Russian has yeah you can make
something human animators have honed
this technique for hundreds of years how
you can make something like Bambi that
looks like a deer but actually looks
better than a deer to us okay so I I
agree with you but from a different
direction so I I think the future of AI
and robots is not to try to mimic a
person okay a person is not even an
ideal form no right right there if four
tasks that you want to conduct the human
body is like what you why would you
design that it's not the case even with
the the the people who don't have legs
but they run track on the blades on
blades
yeah we're not trying to duplicate the
bones of a foot and I put flesh on and
say now you're you know it's like we got
something better something better
something better here's something that
is spring is a propel you forward yes
yes sir so in your in your lab are are
people thinking of the task they need
not trying to duplicate a human because
we just people make babies all the time
what do you need to make a robot human
we have heat real humans I think people
like this fascination with recreating
ourselves but like I really don't see
the point
I think we're all in agreement oh yeah I
mean I've never thought of it that way
but you're right
I think you know when you look at the
time five movies like a alien comes to
mind and the the
so-called android robot is so human that
it's indistinguishable indistinguishable
but the problem is it doesn't have a
soul so it can't make any more it it's a
sociopath let's get to that next okay
okay
she's a robot system guys like right oh
that's the sweet spot okay this is your
uncanny valley right okay gotta take a
break when stark talk returns more about
the evolving relationship between robots
we're back start talking Neil deGrasse
Tyson your host Chuck nice that's right
Kate darling duh duh okay Darley in from
Boston thanks for your Cambridge
specifically the MIT Media Lab good
stuff happens every time something
amazing is happening it's traceable back
to the MIT labs
funny how that works just-just-just not
only like art science and robotics
science and computing and just in in and
culture yeah so this is congratulations
to all y'all oh yeah it's just me I mean
you the one all right I just I just
wanna pick up on where we left off
this idea that you talked about in the
alien series there was a huge that there
was a human who was not human right so
not even humanoid Android Android
Android yeah and you're cool until you
realize they would make a different
ethical choice than you would yeah yeah
so so so do you have to program this in
is this something they can learn there's
a whole field called machine ethics that
looks at can you program ethics into
machines and it turns out that's really
really hard because we don't even fully
program so I mean you ain't got yourself
so I would prefer maybe not to create
robots that have to make those kinds of
ethical decisions but there are people
who are who are trying to solve that
problem okay and so but it would also be
a way if some oh so let's get back to
the concept of soul but a religious
person would say the soul gives you a
sense of right and wrong and purpose
yeah and these sorts of things and then
I was the idea with Bishop Bishop didn't
have a soul so if it meant that bringing
back this life-form to earth that could
potentially wipe out all humans it
doesn't make a difference because it's
in the experiment right it's in the
interest of experimentation and
exploration so who cares
I think this is people's greatest fear
about scientists going astray yes yeah
so will that be the hardest thing to
program into robot a soul
[Laughter]
three lines of code actually believe
certain things have sold yeah so like
there's this Japanese roboticist who
creates these very very lifelike
Androids like he's made one of himself
Hiroshi Ishiguro is his name and mm-hm
she grew and like it seems that in you
know Eastern cultures that have a
history of Shintoism and and believe
that you know even objects can have a
soul like they have funerals for sewing
needles for example it seems that their
little art yeah yeah that must've been a
badass sewing needle some good stuff we
burned a lot of socks for Needy we do
well so tell me I I was unfamiliar with
this so keep going yeah and and we don't
have that concept in in more
judeo-christian society we have Oh
things are alive and have a soul things
are not alive don't have a soul and so
there's this are they're only human
right yeah depending on you know yeah
but that's why some people say that the
Japanese are much more accepting of
robots and this idea of having humanoid
and Android robots around because okay
that's cool they're also more accepting
of robots in the uncanny valley uh they
might be again like I said the empirical
testing on the uncanny valley has kind
of been mixed so there's not a good
scientific basis for it but anecdotally
yes but see and part of their conveyed
is it part of the fact that in their
culture they have a greater need for
robots I mean it is clear that they have
like in Japanese healthcare they don't
have enough people and you have a great
advancement of robotics in that
particular arena are using robots with
automation no I'm talking about actual
robot care I mean and different like for
instance in a hospital like for the
delivery of certain things a robot will
do that rather than rather than orderly
right you know so for instance or just
just
even go outside of healthcare hotels
that you go to where they have robot
check-in and it'll be like a
Tyrannosaurus Rex we'll check you into
the hotel yeah you know a robotic a
robotic trim because because it's a
novelty that's how much into robots they
are that we are not you know so it's so
it's and what about Shintoism enables
that or empowers it drives it some
people would say that that makes them
more willing to accept robots as this
thing that's alive but not really alive
so the simple element of inanimate
objects having souls that alone that's
sufficient so that is one reason people
think the Japanese are more accepting of
robots another reason is like you said
the need is robots come more into these
shared spaces and people interact with
them more people just get used to them
and then there's also the fact that
their science fiction and pop culture
tends to be less dystopia and when it
comes to robots like they have Astro Boy
and these positives I grew up with Astro
Boy Astro Boy bombs away on his mission
today
rocket high to the sky I don't remember
that cuz I just made it up no that was
the that was yeah all that and it was
those had speed racers there was a lot
of sort of early and I was that early
Japanese adamant that there made it to
American television and yeah it was all
very very happy story yeah and we have a
lot of terminator and stories of the
robots taking over we are so messed up
here I never CC that's what happens when
somebody drops a nuclear bomb on you you
know yeah right you have a whole other
la your dystopian future involves like
nuclear holocaust everything else is
just like happy-go-lucky okay
Japan did come up with Godzilla alright
and although Godzilla was formed out of
genetic mutations from nuclear holocaust
the nukes are all in yeah that story
told that's it yeah it makes sense yeah
so so our our that is the Japanese
culture a good
bellwether for the global acceptance and
trajectory of robots that's a good
question um not necessarily not
necessarily I think that maybe the ways
that they will want to use robots are
different okay like the fact that they
like Androids and I don't really think
that we do in Western society yeah but
it'd be interesting to see if all
countries have equal access to this
technology what they'll come up with to
their own cultural needs sure cuz we had
on Startalk on the TV show and I forget
her name but she is an AI representation
of FGM still making around she was on
evening Sophia yes Sophia was a little
was for me in that in that zone she was
going out on she was in the uncanny zone
for me yeah yes exactly it's a little
it's a little disconcerting it's there's
something jarring about it it's called
the uncanny so Anthony Daniels we're
featuring my clips with him he has an
interesting perspective on what makes
c-3po more human than a robot who does
his perspective cuz he he was he is
c-3po
so let's check it out and George came
came up with this idea of this kind of
figure this art deco figure then he
employed Ralph McQuarrie who made this
life-changing paintings that I saw of
the character and then there's more the
sculptor turn that into 3d and made this
beautiful face that people recognize and
interesting that I only just realized
the other day because I was trying to
cheat in Photoshop because some some
some robot faces are just scary and this
is actually very it's it's got its got
curiosity in it and it's but it's you
want to know what he's thinking because
he clearly is thinking and partly is
that sort of wide-eyed
almost babyish there with with with big
eyes he um and what was interesting Liz
had actually and I never realized it
until recently created something that
wasn't machine perfect who wasn't
symmetrical about a center point it is
actually as in a human face I tried to
flip it in Photoshop to double it up to
make it perfect and it doesn't work
because he is a symmetric and that is
one of the clues I think to his humanity
that's an interesting philosophical
point because there's been research on
symmetry and there's a whole off-ramp
from that research that says let me it's
not an off-ramp maybe it's an on-ramp
that a little bit of asymmetry brings
interest to a character to an image to a
painting yeah to art perfection there's
nothing more to say it's like somebody
did it already
right now just between you me you do
have a very symmetric face let me just
just stay with you here
I personally don't if you come off if
you cut me here we go yeah you are so
symmetric yes would I like you were
perfect I probably too late now I think
we have to go with what we've got booked
had a picture of his the robot and so I
put the other half of him next to his
head
but what a genius design tactic to
actually purposely put in a symmetry
tell me about perfection I mean I hadn't
heard about this asymmetry thing before
that's really interesting but one of the
tricks that a lot of robot designers use
in social robotics is to you know if
you're gonna give it a face don't make
it as human-like as possible and don't
give it too many features like don't
necessarily give it AI brows or nose
just eyes is enough things that we
automatically respond to like he was
saying like the big eyes the babyish
face things that we kind of
evolutionarily respond to or the best
the best design tricks right because
babies there
head grows only by a factor of three and
the body grows by a factor of five or
six so babies have a disproportionately
large head right through their body I
push one out of me tell me about okay
you have the power you don't have to do
it you don't have to biologically
recreate the rest of us we do that and
we could yeah so I think that the
argument from evolutionary biology stamp
or at least what I'd learned from my
colleagues here at the American Museum
of Natural History here's a commercial
is that in order to prevent mammals from
killing their children the children have
to look cute yeah
and so the not not that everyone would
kill their children but I'm just saying
I would yeah no they're it's not that
you would want to kill them all the time
there are occasions right in the arc of
raising children where you if they
weren't cute that would we got we go
extinct a long time ago have you done
research into what the what our
relationship with robots says about us
emotionally a little bit I could talk
about this all day but it's kind of like
you know how when you're going to date
with someone and they're really mean to
the waiter and you're like that's a red
flag
some of our research indicates that if
you know you're mean or violent to a
lifelike robot that might say something
about you as a person
oh wow you know that makes sense it's so
the Boston Dynamics has these videos
online of robots being abused and I know
clearly that's a thing that's not a
person and I gotta tell you it is so
hard to watch because they're hitting it
with bats and they're kicking it and
they're knocking it over it's a robot
that's trying to walk basically you see
those yeah and and and it's really
disturbing it's like people get really
upset yeah the first time that they put
one out there looked kind of like a dog
and they
named it spot and then they're like
kickin it and it's like struggling to
stay on its feet people got so upset
that PETA the animal rights organization
was getting a bunch of phone calls and
had to issue a press statement and they
didn't even take it seriously they were
like yeah we're not gonna lose any sleep
over this it's not a real dog but there
actually might be something there okay
okay so would you preemptively
I mean just like it's just like what's
that movie Tom Cruise yeah yeah the
Minority Report is this how you would
pre diagnose someone's propensity to
well you sort of already said so because
in a date
someone behaves in a way that is uh
right to someone who they have power
over right I mean it's afraid now robots
are still really primitive and we're
still able to like mentally
compartmentalize but as the design gets
more and more lifelike I mean we do
definitely draw connections between
animal abuse and child abuse in the same
household legally if you have a case of
one you look for a case of the other and
it's possible that long correlations are
established okay all right and if you
have a robot that can like mimic pain
and suffering and you enjoy inflicting
that on it like that might be an
indicator that you might also enjoy
torturing an animal but we don't know we
don't have the evidence this this
requires more research all right it's
certainly evidence that you're a dick so
interesting so in the dating scene these
are like secondary cues to they can be
really nice to you but the waiter not so
much we kick the Roomba it's over see
what you do is you got what you have you
got a do you the research on your day if
you know your dates into robots but you
better be on your best behavior with all
the robots in dramatically right right
right
that's gonna be the case given the
examples of the Boston Dynamics and
people kicking in and you feel the
emotion for something that is not alive
right
where do laws ultimately have to land
with regard to rights for robots well it
depends
I believe in evidence-based policy so
really yes later checked out have you I
know like really like it would be nice
to have some evidence right and if if
for example we found out that it was
actually desensitizing to people to
behave really violently towards life
like robots then you know there's some
question of whether we should regulate
and say you're not allowed to do certain
things to certain types of robot because
the fostering behavior that would be
yeah there happens to the interest of
civilization so the only actually has an
impact on that behavior actually I have
to say that makes a lot of those
evidence-based makes a lot of sense very
very hopeful there's but it's tough to
research yeah okay so you you can
imagine a future where that's the case
oh yeah
have you watched Westworld that TV show
yeah yeah I mean Rachel yeah it's it's
pretty good but like you could imagine
if we had a theme park like that people
would get upset right right however well
I'm not gonna so actually my clip of
this segment uh-huh I talked to Anthony
Daniels about robots today just just to
get a sense of what is because you know
that character dates from the 70s
great so just what were his thinking
about the interaction of humans and
robots today agenda I'm one of the
frustrations we have now with with
machines that pretend to be human and
and certainly in Japan there are
companies working on human are leading
the way on that every time I see a new
robot is a Japanese robot well they like
that kind of thing they've slightly
taken it to their own in the sense of
social interactions with machines human
to machine human-cyborg relations
indeed George was there first yes some
of them were in early stages of real
robotics and we have to think what we
want from that but when you have
something that pretends to be human and
then sort of suddenly malfunctions it's
like well we're talking about Stepford
Wives
suddenly I'm alerting to all these that
the thing about if you've given us a
full review of 20th century robots here
this is great and 20th century of film
writers script writers who now very I
think urgently have adopted this
slightly outer world netherworld where
we are going not in my lifetime I hope
because I need the work how come I shall
come back to that and of course in in
Japan it it's widely known that they are
looking for really human relatable
probably you know bed bed sized machines
that people can relate to but then you
have to look at how you what kind of
figure physically do you supply because
if it's too humanoid and it starts
clicking and then you it's a little
scary isn't right if it's too mechanical
then you're relating to I don't know
kind of fizzy drink it's like where's
the balance between who I want to
believe I'm relating to because if I get
too fond of you and you're a machine
it's not going to end happily there all
kinds of off ramps there for where that
would go so what is there any thinking
in your lab about human robot
relationships bond bonding yes and where
does that land well for me and a lot of
my colleagues I feel like we're as
humans capable of a lot of different
types of relationships and to me the
relationship with a robot isn't
necessarily the replacement of a human
relationship it's more like how we would
treat a pet or something completely
different and new so it's not something
that's a white no but maybe not but I
think that's an enlightened outlook it's
not clear to me that that's where that's
gonna go
I think people you know if if people can
have imaginary friends then they can
have a robot that that becomes a friend
that becomes a friend well why is that
bad no no I'm asking you is it is there
should we I I don't
mean to imply it's inherently bad I'm
asking you have you guys thought about
whether or not it's well the what i
keeps me up at night is it isn't that
someone might bond or have like a friend
as a robot it's that a company is making
that robot and maybe is using the robot
to emotionally manipulate that person
that already happens yeah toys know
what's called advertising yeah you're
absolutely right
psychological brain screw called
advertising but no I remember the it was
like a furry or a Furby or something but
it's a little robot and it's like and it
says things like I love you and you're
my friend and it's like you know like I
was like I would never get that from my
kid like that's a loneliest kid in the
world that needs this toy that's like
giving it love and affection and and
reinforcement there was an episode of
The Twilight Zone where there's a guy
isolated on a planet asteroid somewhere
is early before they knew how great what
space was really gonna be by name he's
on an asteroid and his asteroid
apparently has a breathable atmosphere
but hoping that it's a holding outside
these complement these the holding that
aside right okay they couldn't be
rescued for like a long time he's
slightly going crazy so they brought him
a robot a female robot okay and it says
turn here and then she comes to life
comes to life of course it's played by
an actual actress but it doesn't matter
she's a robot
and then it's say they're their
companions and they're there for like a
year and then the rescue mission finally
comes but there's no room on the ship
for her I didn't know what he gets back
well we're going back without your
companion there's no but she sees she's
in it I love her guy takes out his gun
shoots her in the head
what and then the springs come out and
the thing and it said let's go
who does that
no the other guy who's trying to save
his composed his fellow astronaut to
remind him that so so what time talk to
me okay but yeah I mean robots can fill
a void like that they're already being
used as an animal therapy replacement in
nursing homes because we can't use real
animals and so you bring in this baby
seal robot that gives you the sense of
nurturing something and people become
very attached to them Wow no so I'm
asking the ethics of the story I just
shared with you oh well I I mean I think
it's unethical to shoot a lady robot
okay but otherwise damaging otherwise
they all die because there's only one
seat on that rescue ship yeah yeah
that's the construct yes and you're an
ethicist talk to me woman talk to me
thank you now we don't have to resolve
the ethical issue no but tell me how
would you wear can't it can't be
unhealthy though this this bonding that
you're talking about it can be yeah I
mean if it's being used to manipulate
someone or if they're bonding with
something so it sounds like she was
meant to be a tool and they didn't
anticipate that he would bond with her
this much yes and this happens in the
real world this happens with soldiers
bonding with their bomb disposal robots
where they treat them like pets and they
get really upset if they get broken if
they saved your life it does right yeah
Peter Singer is written about soldiers
actually singers schemes it's like the
Princeton philosopher know there are two
Peter singers Peter singer there's a
Peter singer who has written a book
called wired for war about military
robots oh and they're apparently
soldiers have risked their lives to save
the robots that they work with they're
actually missing the point of that robot
yeah well robots to save their life yeah
yeah yes kind of bond with something if
it saves your life though and I don't
think the people who deployed that
really anticipated that response
interesting okay so here's the question
then if you're gonna make it empirical
there's the risk to his psychological
health having no companion for a year
versus the risk to a psychological
health of having a companion that you
put a bullet through her head right
which of those is worse I mean not
having a background in psychology my
guess would be ethically I mean you know
we get pets and we know they're gonna
die and this is a similar thing like
that's true
you get dog ain't gonna be around 20
years we take a break when we come back
more of the relationship between humans
and robots
we're back Startalk we're exploring the
relationship between the robots and
humans featuring my interview with the
Daniels who recently published the book
I am and we have with us as an expert
commentator Kate darling okay
reintroducing you to those who whoever
comes in only in the third segment I
don't know who that is animals that's it
so anyway thanks for bringing your MIT
lab perspectives for us so one of my one
of the aspects of anything details that
enchanted me is that he has an academic
affiliation hmm let's check it out okay
um maybe I shouldn't call you
Anthony Daley's I should call you
professor Daniels this is I'm I know
fundamentally an academic so I write my
radar what's up well you can call me a
professor but I know where you're going
because I'm not a professor I am a kind
of visiting mm professional at Carnegie
Mellon car now one of the leading
institutions in computer science and
robotics and everything you know
automated yeah but I years ago I got
connected with it you curious
circumstances through the robot Hall of
Fame they invited me it's a Institute
institution in the Science Museum
they're in Pittsburgh they contact him
he would I come and accept an award for
c-3po to be part of their exhibit yes of
course traveling and I don't mean to
brag hey I don't mean to brag but I'm in
the Bronx Hall of Fame just so you know
don't get too big-headed
I'm in the Bronx okay and they
understand your exit but on the way that
where is the where is the whole train
it's in the center of Pittsburgh is in
the Science Museum for and for instance
you know they've got they've got to
c-3po they got out to d2 they've got a
baseball machine that can pot a ball
every time get that hoop every time
bigger a basketball a basketball it can
do it mechanically every time perfectly
no matter where you put it in the
we're just from there one spot I think
you yeah is cheating isn't it yeah and
they've got the one of the original arms
of that original could pick up an egg
and put it there and just do that all
the time they've also gone oh so they
have the history history and at the time
that would have been quite remarkable
together to do anything it was the first
it was the first what was a industrial
robot there was there it is it's got to
be able to pick up an egg and not break
it not break it but also put it exactly
two replicas and do you know the
definition of a robot has changed now
from the as Marvin days to where we are
a machine that can do something kind of
that's useful
it just doesn't need a human to do it
they also have for instance a room as
large as this which is a medicine
dispensary which is apparently far far
more accurate than having a human
dispenser in a hospital it's dishing out
the drugs but in a good way so guys what
if you visited that Hall of Fame let's
assume they have all robots what would
be your favorite robot cake my favourite
robot they only have real ones right
like not science fiction
well no c-3po is in there is wall-e
there I like wall-e you're allowed even
though they give us they just have a
drawing of wall-e will give you a wall-e
you're like well that's cute I like that
okay how about you alien covenant which
wasn't the best movie in the world but
Michael Fassbender oh yeah hot robot but
not as hot as what's-his-face in AI he
was the male sex robot after yeah just
um God did I just go gay for robots
Oakley did it totally totally did anyway
Michael Fassbender plays two robots he
plays himself he plays Walter who has no
emotions but then he plays Walters evil
twin who does
and they're both robot and they're both
robots but the one without emotions
believe it or not easily manipulated by
the one who has emotions because when
you're evil you can do evil but when you
don't have any emotions and you and you
and you're susceptible you're just
susceptible to anything wait so that's
your favorite role
yeah yeah which one the evil washer no
why because I don't have it in me to be
that and I think in some I think maybe
if I did it what I would feel
differently maybe you need it to
complete you Oh would that be cool so at
what point do you think about the good
and evil that it robot might or might
not do either because they're programmed
to or because they learn it on their own
right yeah I don't think we think about
it in terms of inherent good or evil but
more how is the technology being used by
those who should know the difference
between good and evil yes hey you men
Missy
now apparently at some point these
machines will be programmed by
algorithms hit written by people even if
they're written by other machines
written at some point by people and good
and evil will be kind of inherent in
that algorithm yeah it's gonna be a
whole mess of gray well I had to take
the conversation there okay the future
of AI infused in robots let's see what
Anthony Daniel says I am a little
frightened by AI and you're quite right
to come in to deal with the talks of the
students with an objective eye that I
hate I don't know any I didn't really
understand much of the science but I
have an outer perspective and gradually
through practice you know I'm enjoying a
virtual reality augmented reality all
these sort of things that are gradually
bringing the theatrical user if you will
be entertainment user into the scene so
you're not just a asset-backed
participant you you are actually
involved
so maybe the the gradualism of this
prevents anyone from even noticing the
day that AI takes over I think kind of
that's already happening but in the
world of entertainment which is what the
entertainment Technology Center is about
the growth in in involving entertainment
it is very very marked you know with all
these headsets coming onto the leap
motion and all that kind of thing but in
a world where robots are going to
industrialize jobs and take jobs away
from humans which they've already begun
doing yeah we better look to what humans
can do apart from twiddle their thumbs
so let me let me ask you now then
whatever you were not thinking about
evil in the moment how about evil in the
future about AI turning evil how about
have have let me ask you a tighter
question has AI as portrayed in film
gone the right places that we all should
be thinking about we're missing
something yes they're missing a ton and
I love science fiction I think that
science fiction opens people's minds to
thinking about what's possible but we
have so many dystopian stories of robots
taking over that people are fearing
robot uprisings when that's very
premature and we should be worried about
other things that are happening right
now but you didn't say that it wouldn't
happen you just said it's premature
so 2027 so tell me so what where should
we be focused well there are a lot of
issues right now with privacy data
security supplement versus replacement
of human ability with you know
reinforcing racial gender stereotypes in
the design of these technologies like
all of this is happening right now
there's autonomous weapon systems being
developed there's things we should be
concerned about that aren't the robots
becoming smart and taking over the world
I think that that one also tends to be a
lot of rich white dudes worried about
that one because they don't have to
worry about the other stuff they're just
like my only danger is that a robot
makeup me
I don't have to worry about like facial
recognition holding me sociologically
insightful plus you've seen the racial
sinks in bathrooms the racist sinks no I
don't know about this no they can't see
black hands yeah and we've done this
with all types of Technology because
it's all white dudes building right and
so I just thought it was the sink didn't
work I chanted waiting for the water
who's an automat has happened to them
and nothing so maybe that sink doesn't
work so they go to another sink then I
wave my hand some more eventually you
know it'll hit so if you do the
experiment you put in a darker surface
or a lighter surface it's it's it's
reflecting reflects it yeah reflecting
reflecting the light right right so what
you're saying is white men say it white
man there's also a lot of gender stuff
right right we'll design things thinking
that they are the model of what it is
and should be
and and capturing their concerns but
it's also not their fault like we all
view the world through our own
experiences and so the problem is that
we don't have diverse teams building
technology that's really where it is it
is their fault if they're not hiring you
or Chuck trying to stave off viral day
[Laughter]
yes sir you're hired
but we don't want any trouble no but you
raised it a very important point if if
I'm stereotyping here but if white men
are programming all of the code that
will be the future of AI it could have
remarkable remarkably biased
consequences as an unintended concept is
right you're speaking about this as
though this is in the future but this is
actually happening right now well got
you listen yeah I know that's why my
hands are dirty
Chuck can clean his hands and you don't
know when alright so how about this
let's let's try to land this plane okay
what do you what do you think is our
largest F
dilemma going forward I think the thing
I worry about the most is that a lot of
AI the way it's built right now realized
on data collection they need massive
amounts of data and so I worry about
privacy because there's no incentive to
curb that right now
interesting because if you want to know
all about humans you want got to know
and we want to do everything they do but
then other people will also have access
to that data governments will companies
will and that's already happening in
China where they're collecting
information privately but then the
government forces them to turn over the
information including facial recognition
that happens on just the streets of the
cities yeah all that camera data yeah
how to identify foreign national exactly
one round them up right right exactly so
yeah so how do we lean into because I do
think there are so many positive use
cases for this text so how do we lean
into those positive use cases and curb
some of this stuff that's nuts that
question I'm asking I'd appreciate ask
that no all right so hmm
let's get some parting thoughts a
parting thought here I you know I'm I'm
really I'm really disturbed by the fact
that there are racist things man okay
sorry to take you off the rail Chuck
it's okay give me give us something
hopeful here reflecting on it all okay
I'll give you something hopeful so you
know how people are sometimes nice to
robots and then they feel silly about it
like they'll say excuse me to their
robot vacuum cleaner or they'll like say
please or thank you to Alexa the Amazons
assistant I don't think people need to
feel silly about that because I think
that what that is saying is that their
first instinct is to be kind to another
and so what I really really love about
robots is that
they are kind of a reflection of our own
humanity in a way I mean our
interactions with the robot yeah our
interactions with them that's cool
that's cool I like that so if you're a
good person a robot will tease that out
of you but if you're a bad person the
robot will do this you're bringing it
somewhere dark robots are good she tried
unless they saw she was trying I know
help woman some help here okay okay all
right so it can be give us insight into
humanity yes into our own empathy and
psychology and how we relate to others
so we can learn more about ourselves
from interacting with robot cool because
I don't think that's been explored much
in storytelling no it hasn't right
actually that is a very good like
platform to use as a jumping-off point
for like it has been explored but it's
not what everyone's thinking about or
talking about right right right so
here's what I think not that you asked
but we don't care but Media Lab that is
the real side of anything out here I
think and I don't even know if I have
foundation to think this way I think the
apocalyptic scenarios are overplayed I
think we always we always deal into our
base lowest fears mm-hmm because fear
tends to always override our joys that's
natural I think first for survival right
you can you know if you're not afraid of
something and it kills you then gone is
the gene to be afraid of stuff that will
kill you right so you take it out of the
gene pool so I think that's been
overplayed my worry is that our
distraction with the evil prevents us
from thinking more creatively about the
good that robotic AI can bring to this
world
and I don't I don't want to lose out on
the creative solutions that they can
bring so so Kate I put it entirely on
your shoulders yeah this office is not
called the Media Lab this is just Neil's
office today all right we'll just in the
crib we're gonna send you back home
back to your back to your peeps and we
want you to solve this problem
challenge accepted excellent Chuck
always a pleasure
good to have you Kate thanks for coming
down from Boston thank you so much for
having all right and now we know you up
there will surely do this again
absolutely will totally take it to
another place yeah because that your
kind of expertise doesn't have to walk
up and down the street all the time so
we're digging this yeah you've been
watching possibly listening to this
episode of Startalk robots and humans
and I just want to thank Kate Chuck and
do the show absolutely as always I bid
you to keep looking up